hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the month I know what is snow
it's the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and all
just checking it all yeah sorry I'm
saving my voice I [ __ ] up my voice a
couple months ago and I just ignored it
and now I am trying to throw coding
teeing it I got some halls sucking on
the halls there dude it's the [ __ ]
mantle left it whatever the [ __ ] says
on the thing halls mental lipless
mentholyptus eucalyptus I don't know
take a steam what you need to do for
your voice is you need to stop talking
you need to drink some condensed milk
it's like 20 people right now who else
we closed phlegm shut the [ __ ] up you
never went to medical school okay all
you did was drink a glass of milk stop
talking like you're a [ __ ]
veterinarian uh you know I didn't want
to be in a mood like this um all right
so Billy no fun
now I've cried wolf for about three
weeks right now talking about how I was
going to get my act together right I was
going to I was going to start working
clean on stage I was going to you know
get my relationship with Christ going
again now I'm talk to that guy like the
[ __ ] forever we had a big falling out
me and that guy you know and I still
feel like he owes me the apology I'm
waiting for him to call you know waiting
for him to reach out but you know I
could see that he's being a big baby
about it so evidently you know I'm going
to be the bigger man you know I'm going
to have to reach out Jesus it because
could you help least avoid the demon of
the booze now I was good this is how
this is how much I've been eating and
drinking like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I just
shut everything down Sunday night and I
lost 4 pounds this week
you know just [ __ ] and I even got
hammered one night I was doing so well
dude the fourth of July happy birthday
dear United States of America happy
birthday United States of America happy
birthdays defenders of freedom you live
in on goop and we want to pay oh Jesus
anyways on July 4th
you know me burgers I had zero
how many hotdogs I had zero
you know much alcohol I had zero until a
couple came over our friends you know
they brought their kids over you know
they had a little one then they had one
that was like seven eight years old he
was a riot telling knock-knock jokes he
was killing me killing me this delivery
was outstanding he was making up his own
knock-knock jokes but just the way he
would do to deliver the punchline I'd be
like okay I got one I got one
he's just making them up on the spot
he'd be like knock-knock I'd be like
who's there and you'd be like Liz and
Liz it wouldn't be like Liz and to my
music I mean you come up with one on the
spot those aren't easy anyways so we end
up having I had a great time but you
know the guy brought over some beer so
I'm like yet he's not cold I got a
couple of Coors look the Coors liking on
the little grenade [ __ ] bottles in
the back I'm like I'll have one so I
have one
they were only here for an hour right
but what did I do
I sprinkled a little fairy dust on the
demon in me and then the demon woke up
was like walk over to Paul Ricca trip
tequila and I did you know big [ __ ]
square ice cube nice home pool
and the bottle was almost empty so I'm
like well I gotta have another one and
finish that one now long story short one
and a half of those plus the [ __ ]
course and I'm downstairs my bed talking
gibberish to my wife I just know at one
point she just goes why as I time to go
to bed so I one minor slip-up you know
whatever I think we just did heroin once
a week that wouldn't be bad right you
just did once you know maybe on the
weekend so you wouldn't want to nod not
for work so I'd be bad there be
hilarious if you just stuck to your guns
I'd be like four out of five days I'm
[ __ ] on it one [ __ ] day I come in
here with track marks not enough of my
cubicle also oh oh we need to have a
meeting that's an 80% it's a b-minus
tell me your parents would ground you
over a b-minus they just say get your
grades up this is it get your grades up
conversation then I'm all about it but
if you're going to start saying you're
gonna fire me you're going to fire me
over a b-minus over a B - okay I'll get
a [ __ ] lawyer I'll sue the [ __ ] out
of you Your Honor my my client was only
doing heroin once a week okay it was it
was the middle of the week it was
Wednesday okay he came any question on
Monday and Tuesday Wednesday mitad Lee
he wasn't worth anything but Thursday
and Friday he finished strong we could
equate this to a sports analogy you know
when I didn't uh 104 20 in the beginning
of the third quarter but he came out
with a victory sorry anyways just so I
lost four pounds this [ __ ] week and I
think I'm back on it I you know what I
have an acting gig coming up so I got to
get down to my fighting weight is Bob
pogo this Dave Koechner is Bob pogo says
my finding weight is 172 so I can drop
three a week it's in two weeks I'll be
down to like 170 [ __ ]
three four something like that and then
I'll just [ __ ] win the next two off
while I do the shoe there you go that's
how it's done all right all you fat
actresses out there
I could [ __ ] morning to complain oh
it's so easy for a [ __ ] guy we got
our fighting weight too you know so sick
of that [ __ ] myth that they put out
the guy can look however he wants now if
your fest spots are going to play a fat
[ __ ] is a guy it's just what it is
you're going to play a fat [ __ ] and the
jokes are going to be that you're a fat
[ __ ] okay you're going to be doing a
Chippendales dance with no shirt on
you're going to be breaking coffee
tables you'll be living in a van down by
the river you're going to be a mall cop
that tries to slide behind a pole but
doesn't quite make it because of the
shape he's in okay I don't know what
[ __ ] movies you're watching and then
the whole thing will they sit there and
they go you know I'm so sick of seeing
these movies where there's these guys
and these these women you know they're
with women half their [ __ ] age well
you know what that is is because you
haven't traveled to where the money is
go down in Miami you know get out of the
ugly parts of the world like Des Moines
Iowa okay Wow come on you know you're
ugly and if you're not ugly
you're [ __ ] planning an escape all
the hot chicks move out of Des Moines
where do they go Cheyenne Wyoming you
know then they meet some hot guy from
Greeley next thing you know they're in
Denver growing some weed Greeley we're
having a bad smell day anyways you know
a friend of mine was just talking
recently about this farm that they have
they sponsor this farm somewhere out in
England and they they don't kill the
cows when they stop producing milk they
just let them kind of just get old it's
really cool it's like a cool farm man
they milk the cows by hand I think all
farms should do that you know all farms
should do that and if there's you know
if they can't keep up with the milk
supply demand that you know all that
means is human beings will die and
considering where the problem you know I
say as long as it's not me or anyone
that I love I'm all for
here's some really fucked-up
environmentally I started watching
baseball again I finally gave in I
bought the MLB package
I'm all set now I got the scent of rice
I got the [ __ ] what's this listen
they always got some dumb name they
can't just say the NHL against the
center ice the courtside [ __ ] 50-yard
line whatever they call them right I got
the Bruins the Patriots the Celtics and
let's I got the whole [ __ ] thing with
my cable it just automatically renews
which I love I usually don't like when
it automatically renews like hey hey I
make the decision now I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm still a guy fine whatever
whatever it's fine don't worry about it
so I've been watching i watch that
Rangers series I didn't realize how many
Red Sox I didn't know he's Mookie Betts
and right
Bradley Jacob jr. something like that
Bradley a [ __ ] Walmart jr. whatever
the [ __ ] his name is Milton Bradley
what's his name something Bradley jr. I
don't know then you got Andrew ready
here bad and the [ __ ] left Xander
Bogaerts
Dustin Pedroia I don't know a lot of
them anyway so I'm gonna start watching
them and watching the Yankees too
because Aaron Judd Aaron judge looks
like a [ __ ] miss doesn't he he looks
like one of those [ __ ] things when
they talk about baseball in the early
1900s you know they had those giant
[ __ ] you know elephantitis of the
[ __ ] hand gloves that they used to
play with you know guys [ __ ] amazing
I don't know what's going on though but
I think baseball's numbers are done I
think they juice up whenever they
whenever that [ __ ] numbers go down I
believe that they juice up the ball they
got to do something I mean it's all of a
sudden I don't know where everybody just
starts cranking all these [ __ ]
homeruns this guy's on pace to hit like
[Music]
but anyways I've been not just sitting
there recording the games were in Tampa
tonight right we started you know what
happened was I went did that Big Papi
roast and then I went to the game and
then I
just got back into it I was like oh yeah
I [ __ ] love this game I forgot about
that
and I think we went to Tehran a'ight so
I went to Toronto when that series went
to Rangers I Texas right this what I
understand this what the [ __ ] I was
trying to get to was I'm watching the
[ __ ] Texas Rangers they had that
amazing ballpark I went there i sat up
sat in the outfield because I wanted to
have the opportunity to run out on the
grass to try to get one of those home
runs you know and I've just found out
that [ __ ] ball park it's not even 25
years old they're already bare already
knocking it down all that concrete all
of that [ __ ] all of that [ __ ] stuff
somebody please do a documentary and
follow the dump trucks and just show
where does that go what are we going to
do with all that [ __ ] it's fine it's
[ __ ] fine like well you know gets
really hot out here in the summer and we
need a [ __ ] with it gets hot out here
in the summer because of us we're a
[ __ ] plague Jesus Christ you already
[ __ ] yanked all that [ __ ] out of the
goddamn ground now you're just going to
throw it out you're going to throw it in
the [ __ ] ocean and build another one
I don't know they're doing that in
Atlanta Atlanta has a [ __ ] ballpark
that thing's not more than 25 years old
now like well you knew our fan base HGS
too far dry and and I Moo
raelia right they gotta bring it out to
where the white people are right white
people white people you don't have to do
it they're going to move it out to the
where the white people are you know the
problem is is Atlanta Braves fans
[ __ ] suck they just you know it's not
even that they suck it's just they've
had the ball yanked out from underneath
them a zillion [ __ ] times they got
Charlie Brown okay and then you know
after that last [ __ ] Super Bowl if
you think these species [ __ ] I mean
if I was a president I would declare
Atlanta a [ __ ] disaster area if I was
in Georgia all right I would just watch
college sports IBM Georgia Bulldogs
that's what I would do Georgia Tech
University of Georgia other Island I'm
one of my dreams and when I'm wondering
I just want her to come over and just
slobber in my [ __ ] hand I'll go home
and jerk off there's a bug in Georgia
below I would it's disgusting
I will [ __ ] I would be into that [ __ ]
so evidently they feel that not enough
black people come out I have no idea
this is just what people from Atlanta
told me they don't feel enough black
people come out or white people are too
afraid to drive their Chrysler Town and
Country countries and SUVs into the
Greater Atlanta area to go to a [ __ ]
baseball game I have no idea so they're
just abandoning that [ __ ] major
league ballpark that some like college
team is now going to play their baseball
games and it's [ __ ] ridiculous and
then they going to build another one I
know I think you should have to be in a
ballpark for at least 50 [ __ ] years
right I be honest with you I can't
believe how old those were I thought
they made those in like in the year 2000
I thought they made them 2000 made him
like 94 or something like that so I
don't know who cares you know who gives
a [ __ ] right just keep yanking the [ __ ]
out of the [ __ ] drought building [ __ ]
rip it down and then throw it in the
ocean and then blame people with red
ties blue
we'll just continue doing what the [ __ ]
would it's depressing girl
this is [ __ ] depressing all right how
about some good news I have some of the
best news I've gotten in a long time a
long time all right you're ready for
this
the Indianapolis Colts got caught
cheating got caught cheating again it's
[ __ ] on it's disel arias it's [ __ ]
hilarious how many of these [ __ ]
things that these guys do and how little
attention those [ __ ] at ESPN pay
attention to this [ __ ] the level of
[ __ ] focus on Spygate deflategate all
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] they're not even
going to do a story on ESPN like hey
wait a minute we spent two and a half
years on [ __ ] deflategate because the
owner of a team that's gotten caught
pumping and crowd noise [ __ ] having
hearing aids now I guess in the helmets
because Peyton Manning was a new
quarterback and hadn't mastered the
silent count the dude who caught the
under-inflated [ __ ] ball got busted
doing roids they stole our [ __ ]
offense I mean did they they get it
their owners sat on the competition
committee and changes the rules of
passing to tip it in his favor so they
could beat the Patriots it's [ __ ] I
believe there's a thing I'm not mad at
any of that do you like
does that make Indian it does that
really make them win the [ __ ] game
because they have hearing aids in their
[ __ ] helmets I think that's [ __ ]
hilarious all right and I think it's the
job of the league to try to catch those
people doing it and when people get
caught I just laughs corked bats all of
that shit's funny steroids is the one
thing steroids that's the one for me
that I feel that's the biggest thing you
know pumping in crowd noise hearing aids
taking a [ __ ] hair with the air out of
a ball trying to steal signs Jesus
Christ everybody [ __ ] but that shit's
hilarious to me and those are some of
the best stories
that you hear when you listen to pro
athletes half their [ __ ] funny
stories are about guys cheating you know
so every time two restaurants away the
guy keeps punching me in the balls I'm
just like dude what the [ __ ] but it
third quarter my balls are the size of
my [ __ ] head so I turn around and I
kick him in the nuts from behind I get
his paintings [ __ ] answer like every
one of that banquet all of their [ __ ]
stories are about the [ __ ] that they did
to each other when the refs weren't
looking my only one is steroids it's the
only one I give a [ __ ] about if you get
caught using steroids just because that
you know and that doesn't make you throw
the ball farther or see it better or get
bad speed or any of that [ __ ] it just
keeps you feeling brand [ __ ] new
you're going up there like you got eight
hours sleep like you never got tackled
in your life like you never got hit on
the ribcage by a fastball it just you're
like a [ __ ] x-man that's the one that
I look at like what the [ __ ]
but I also I also want to stand it I
mean because at least in football like
what those guys do to their bodies and
what happens to their brains at the very
least I think they ought to be able to
heal up like x-men I think they ought to
be able to smoke weed you know at a
state level so they don't get in trouble
that's the only thing but listen to
think Colts I don't think Peyton
Manning's a cheater I don't think the
Colts are [ __ ] cheaters I think it's
[ __ ] hilarious that you got caught
doing that just because your owner is a
[ __ ] he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
can't believe that ESPN is just going to
[ __ ] ignore this story they're just
ignoring the thing quick little blurb
bing-bang-boom
done see you later is no hey wait a
minute the whole time this guy was
saying by the bed bed meanwhile he's
doing this I mean Jesus Christ ESPN dog
days of summer God knows you got to fill
up some [ __ ] air time as a Patriots
fan can you at least have Bob Lee do
some [ __ ] outside the line [ __ ]
they won't do it net1 [ __ ] do without
whatever what are you going to do I love
it though I love it cuz to this day I
still get [ __ ] when I was up in when I
was up in Port Chester [ __ ] Giants
fans Giants fans who had former great
Giants talk about [ __ ] cheating all
the time all the [ __ ] that they do like
like this [ __ ] guy Jim Irsay
succeeded because he in his own way
tainted the Patriots when they did
absolutely nothing more than anybody
else's [ __ ] doing which is basically
[ __ ] grab-ass [ __ ] and they're
acting like they're [ __ ] I don't know
I don't know I don't know I don't get it
I don't [ __ ] get it you know what I
guess Tom Brady he's just too
good-looking if Tom Brady looked like
Peyton Manning I'm telling you right now
this way and we weren't winning
championships it wouldn't be a [ __ ]
story but whatever all I know is I got
another round of ammunition that I can
put in the gun any [ __ ] time anybody
speaks up about the Patriots cheat now
what do you think about the Indianapolis
Colts huh
how do you feel about the the Falcons or
the the Vikings what do you think about
those guys what do you think about the
Pittsburgh Steelers what do you think
about the New York Football Giants what
do you think about any I you don't think
anything about that you know why because
ESPN didn't tell you to think anything
about it you [ __ ] Buffalo Wild Wings
mouth-breathing file let it go bill
alright oh yeah anyways a buddy of mine
was just brought up that Conor McGregor
Mayweather fight again and it was
[ __ ] hilarious he goes you don't
think McGregor has a chance and I'm just
like I think he's you know I told my god
I think he's an unbelievable
disadvantage you know what I mean he's
like he's like a [ __ ] swimmer and
this is like a fight or no that's a bad
analogy I don't know what I guess I told
you now he it's like [ __ ] Tom Brady
Jerry Rice at the height of their
[ __ ] careers
let's see use a better football player
by seeing who can throw the football
further and more accurate that's the
only level of competition so this guy's
going you don't think he's got a chance
he goes look at his box
and he shows me a [ __ ] MMA fight the
guy throws like three punches and then a
flying [ __ ] knee and takes the guy to
the ground it's a psychic that's not
boxing all right
world class championship boxers could
not lay a [ __ ] glove on this guy he's
not going to be able to land a [ __ ] I
don't even land a glove on him the only
thing he has is if Mayweather I don't
know in the last whenever the last time
he fought was he just got old like
Jordan between the Bulls in the Wizards
like he just had a noticeable [ __ ]
drop off and he can somehow rough the
guy up and I know Mayweather his hands
are [ __ ] up from all the years of
[ __ ] punching guys in the head well
maybe he can [ __ ] somehow get
Mayweather's ego into like he can talk
enough [ __ ] that MMA is a superior sport
that Mayweather's is going to want to
knock him out and maybe he comes in and
for the first time in his career does
something stupid I just don't see it
happening I said that I hate this fight
because I know I'm going to order it but
um after the debate with him and
watching him sending me an MMA clip to
show me how good this guy was at boxing
now but I don't think I'm going to order
the [ __ ] thing I'm gonna wait I'm
gonna wait - people call me up and
ceiling I mean wait for texif like oh
[ __ ]
capital letters then I'll order it or if
they glad was a complete [ __ ] waste
of money then I'll just laugh and I
probably will order anything I'm gonna
order it god damn [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna
order it let me give me whether another
hundred how much [ __ ] money that guy
owes me want you to fight Manny Pacquiao
[ __ ] ten eleven years after when he
should have although I actually I mean I
thought that that guy was on something
you know you know I know cuz I'm not in
the fight game anytime a guy just keeps
moving up in weight class and he just
keeps getting stronger I mean is that
possible
I moved up in weight class I when I
thought you a buck ninety I didn't get
any faster
anyways let's read some [ __ ]
advertising here I'm gonna have to go
into the writers room for season three
of ethics for family oh boy
another ten episodes and I'm being a
[ __ ] angel an angel as far as my
eating in that writers room nothing
nothing will [ __ ] you over like sitting
in the goddamn writers room you're
sitting on your ass all [ __ ] day and
it's candy and chips and chips and candy
and pizza and [ __ ] Burgers and Fries
I mean it is it is it's [ __ ] do you
might as well be sitting in a crack
house this K here's my diet
alright here it for me I feel like this
works alright I have oatmeal third of a
cup of oatmeal with a banana right a
little bit of milk in there to cool off
the [ __ ] these are [ __ ] I don't
know what it is and [ __ ] you guys with
your steel-cut oats I don't give a [ __ ]
this works for me alright then I have
two eggs always that's it right then
between lunch and breakfast I have an
orange that's it and then for lunch I
have some sad [ __ ] salad with the
protein nope right and then I just crush
waters I leave around five I got to eat
something else in the afternoon I don't
look and then I come home and I have a
salad with a protein and I do a half
hour a cardio and that's it the fat has
nowhere to hide
it's like a [ __ ] roach when you turn
the lights on it it's just freezes it
doesn't know what to do and then it's
dead that's it and I just have to what I
have to do is I have to stick with this
so I'm down to just under 180 ml bucks
79 and change so this time next week I
want when I'm in [ __ ] Grand Rapids
Michigan doing my favorite [ __ ] gigs
in the country the fountain Street
[ __ ] Church I'm doing some fun gigs
coming up by the way I want to be 176
next week is what I'm saying but I got a
I'm playing that [ __ ] venue that
Buddy Holly the Big Bopper and Richie
Valens all played the night they died
flying in
the same [ __ ] airport I know what you
guys are saying ah geez well don't you
add your what no no because we actually
have de-icing exists they did not have
that Alright LegalZoom everybody and
that cake is going to be like in a
November Ivan it's not on sale yet as
far as I know alright legalism in order
to successfully run your own business
attention to detail is so critical one
contract slip-up one contract slip-up or
legal misunderstanding can really set
you back fortunately there's LegalZoom
you may already know that over a million
million million Americans have used
Legal Zoom to start their business but
LegalZoom services go well beyond
business formation they built a
nationwide network of independent
attorneys who can provide legal answers
to the day-to-day questions you have
about your business what because let's
face it
things like trademarks employment laws
and lease agreements can get pretty
complicated so now waste your valuable
time trying to wrap you up simple little
head around all the fine print use Legal
Zoom for that so you can focus on
growing your business instead you'll get
the legal help you need without being
built by the hours since Legal Zoom
isn't a law firm go to legalzoom.com
today and be sure to enter code Barbie
you are are in the referral box for
special savings only at legalzoom.com oh
look who's here but oh dude do me on DS
beyond DS the cults used here in age doo
doo doo dude me undies me undies that
ain't Gatorade they [ __ ] cheated
you're a bunch of [ __ ] you got on the
undies so take a dump in your balls feel
good with your silent count you [ __ ]
hypocritical [ __ ] oh yeah five [ __ ]
rings go suck it alright me undies oh
man I that's mind one even my favorite
one ever be on DS what's the first thing
you put on and the last thing you take
off huh it's not your socks you [ __ ]
weirdo it's your underwear make your
most important piece of clothing the
best it can be
with me undies what is me undies you
might have asked oh just seriously soft
feel-good undies delivered right to your
door the undies are designed in LA and
made from sustainably sort that micro
mode al modal a fabric three times
softer than cotton you know what I think
my stomach's three times softer than
micro modal my undies softer than soft
luxury undies comes in an ever-changing
selection of classic colors bold shaped
what our classic colors is that like
your first box of crayons colored bold
shades and adventurous patterns so you
can tailor your undies to your own
personal style and guess what you can
say time and money each month with a
monthly subscription and if you're not
ready for a subscription that's okay
this is great monthly subscription you
know you keep dressing up your junk in a
different way it seems new to your wife
right all of a sudden she's dropping to
her knees putting her Edith Wharton book
on the [ __ ] nightstand going to town
and guess what you can save time and
money each month with a monthly
subscription if you're not ready for a
subscription that's okay you can still
say that's because me undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair just use our
special URL me undies com / / and get
20% off your first pair so go ahead
revamp your underwear drawer you deserve
it you did serve it
once again that's me undies dot-com / /
me undies com / / alright let's finish
with this how about those [ __ ]
Celtics Danny Ainge Ange Ange Ange is
the word number that Larry Barrett
Barrett fired by there's no way he's
making some [ __ ] moves I guess we're
going after this Gordon he would
everybody thinks he's a great fit for
the Boston Celtics because one he's a
great player too he played for coach
Brad Stevens at Butler and three he's
[ __ ] why why why
yeah yeah yeah Celtics love a white guys
still love a white guy boo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo boo boo boo boo I don't
know what it is
the Celtics they just have to have the
white guy i watch this we played Utah I
didn't see what the big [ __ ] deal was
everybody fell oh my god does it guys
[ __ ] unreal he's white like me
[Music]
Jason Tatum we got Jason Tatum drafted
him I saw him play at Duke last year
against Carolina you know I think he's a
great fit for the Celtics you know we
played at Duke under Coach K's an
absolute beast and he appears to be at
least half white he's light-skinned dude
there you go that Celtics like that
I'm [ __ ] with you guys um look at
[ __ ] Danny Ainge becoming like the
[ __ ] red Arabic juniors got all these
draft picks he's [ __ ] wheeling he's
dealing you know what I want to see him
do I want to see him light up a [ __ ]
so you can't do it anymore light up a
[ __ ] cigar we're up by 20 in the
fourth quarter just light it up it's
[ __ ] over red auerbach used to do
that on the bench I mean just one of the
biggest [ __ ] talkers ever without having
to say one word oh my god how bad did
people want to beat that guy alright
anyways that's going to be the podcast
for this week oh you know I got some new
symbols I got a bunch of new symbols I
finally got the jazz ride that I wanted
I still [ __ ] suck but my cymbals
sound great and I'm still my Gretsch kit
that I ordered I ordered it in May they
said it'd take two and a half months so
it's been a month and a half so it
should be here at any moment
no bill it should be here in another
month if you do the math whatever I know
it's going to happen when I [ __ ]
leave to New York and I go to do the
acting gig that's when it's going to
[ __ ] show up Murphy's Law and then
I'm going to come here and they'll be
like sorry we missed you and they're
going to be like we don't know where the
drum kit is you know we set it down
right and then I'm going to [ __ ] and see
some street performer with my [ __ ]
grudge kit and I'm going to know it's
mine because it's going to have three
floor toms like [ __ ] doesn't that
kind of one rack tom
floor toms the triangle of death my
right I'm already going to order another
rack Tom I think I'm just doing
everything I can to have a different
[ __ ] setup so I can get out of my
thirty-year [ __ ] john bonham vortex
that I went down and I've been playing
the double pedal I've been playing a
double pedal to Primus and a little bit
of Pantera just doing whatever I can
listen in lung and then slowing it down
and [ __ ] trying to get my [ __ ] up to
speed and and I've been listening to
like in 1950s Miles Davis typical me
[ __ ] ad D all over the map why work
it one of those things at one time so
you can actually get something down
ville when you can work out with at all
of it at once all of it at once all
right whatever I'm having put the
[ __ ] I mean I'm not the pradhan you
know not gonna be recording anything so
who gives a [ __ ] record anything ever
you know although you know I've been
doing that I did that video that Sunday
video podcast I had a great time doing
that I'm going to do those every once in
a while maybe one of these times
I'll [ __ ] I'll do like a nah I can't
do a draw to a little clip I'll put a
little clip up I got to do a drum cover
of like one of the worst songs ever and
then just be sitting there because it
has to have to somehow make you laugh
right I can't just do a drum cover and
be like yeah well I don't understand
what the purpose of that was what am i
watching the banana splits is like
[ __ ] danger Island going to come on
next oh maybe I'll just do one behind
the drum kit I'll just talk [ __ ] for
[ __ ] half hour and then the second
I'm done I can play drums maybe that's
how I do it and I act like I'm going to
play drums but then I never do and then
you like bill what the [ __ ] and I'll
just be like no what the [ __ ] you
because I made you watch until the end
I'm like bill bill laimbeer right now
I'm playing a mind game
we have to play my games with people is
that what you did go I think you just
way the people left the ground you took
their [ __ ] legs out from underneath
them I didn't realize that that was
something other than a level of mental
[ __ ] going on there I thought you just
understood gravity and somebody being
vulnerable
alright that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves god bless the Indianapolis
Colts not everybody having been through
this is a Patriots fan I want you to be
nice to those Colts fans do not call
them cheaters it isn't fair [ __ ]
hearing aids that is hilarious
could they talk to each other do you
realize how [ __ ] funny that is and
that you sitting on your offensive line
coach comes in I listen this kid ain't
[ __ ] making it man he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] he's doing we're going to
get harassed is this gonna be a loud
building or I just put these [ __ ]
things in anything any one of them sat
there going like but coach isn't that
against the rules that's [ __ ]
hilarious I love that they did that
that's one of my favorite things about
sports you know is that [ __ ] somebody
with Vaseline under there [ __ ] that
guy had the [ __ ] on his neck and it's
just [ __ ] funny
then everybody judges them like you
never drove in the carpool lane without
another person in the car right you
never cheated on a test you never [ __ ]
around on your girlfriend or your
boyfriend you know [ __ ] around in your
taxes huh you never cut in line we're
all [ __ ] cheaters you [ __ ] [ __ ]
holier-than-thou douchebags alright
anyways I mean look is unless you're
doing like steroids or like you're
making somebody you know you [ __ ]
somebody over on a house and then
they're upside down in the house and you
[ __ ] them over for life and then the
senior citizens after you al Pope that's
when that's when you got to step in and
do something but other than that
you know you bust somebody and then you
[ __ ] laugh at you know you never
cheated on your diet your [ __ ] spouse
walks in you got a [ __ ] spoonful ice
cream
there's your cork bat right in your
[ __ ] mouth all right go [ __ ]
yourselves I have a great weekend your
[ __ ] and I love I'll see you on Monday
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah the Monday morning podcast we
have our own Twitter account finally if
you'd like to follow the mm podcast and
get the links for all the videos and all
the stuff that I talked about follow us
here at the mm podcast our twitter
handle is at the MMP podcast at the mm
podcast and MMP is all capitalized solar
power everybody can I take five minutes
just to be a [ __ ] hit me man
[Music]
every once in a while I go in and out of
my [ __ ] you know I'm with the team
and now I'm not and then I'm against the
team you know kind of like a [ __ ]
like a Randy Moss
you know you come into town you got your
mind right and after about a season and
a half you start acting like a [ __ ]
maniac that's how I feel when I look at
whatever the [ __ ] experiment really
trying to avoid the expression the
powers that be but I don't know I can't
help but every time when I land in Los
Angeles and I look out at the Basin as
they call it from the San Gabriel
Mountains all the way south of that
which is [ __ ] LA and greater LA all
of that just what an absolute
[ __ ] it is and what happens when
the [ __ ] hits the fan so I'm thinking
about getting some solar panels and I
know all you rednecks out there say me
obviously the [ __ ] good's the solar
paint I'm going to do you ain't got a
gun what are you going to keep the guy
warm that [ __ ] shoot you in the head
steals your provisions I understand
they're [ __ ] bearded wonder all right
I get it
but I one step at a time one step at a
[ __ ] time first thing I want to do I
want to get you know it's ridiculous I
live in a [ __ ] desert the house bakes
in the Sun and I still have I don't have
solar power two dumbest [ __ ] ever so I'm
going to look into it and what I want to
know is is you know
is that two types of solar power there's
one way you're still on the grid and
then there's one way you're off the grid
I like off the grid and if anybody is
listening to my podcast if you're off
the grid
like what happens do they like it do
they get mad at you I mean out of a no
because all of a sudden your bill goes
down does that like set off a light you
know and underneath the mountain that
all those Illuminati guys live in and
then somebody pulls up to you house
there I noticed you haven't been making
any toast lately and you know what's
going on in how come you know you know
watching TV when you reading books in
their [ __ ] eaten apples off a tree
how come you're not using any electrical
tricity there does that happen is it
it's not illegal to be off the grid they
just sort of [ __ ] do they bully you
at all like oh just let me know what I'm
in for all right because what I would
love to do is it continue spending my
legal tender that really has nothing
behind it other than the faith of every
freckled-faced [ __ ] over here I would
really love to continue existing in this
but I would like to have the backup that
if the [ __ ] does hit the fan before I'm
overrun by a mob you know because mine
is the only light on the top of the hill
see that's I used to do a bit about that
that's the thing like if you actually
have if you're off the grid alright and
everything just goes [ __ ] haywire you
immediately you got to cut your lights
out quick okay because the first thing
when everybody loses power there's
standing oh all you got to be [ __ ]
[ __ ] me I was watching - bro girls
over here right that's the first thing
you flip the switches is it then endless
you know within 30 seconds you're like
is it just our house and you look out
the window so you basically you have 30
[ __ ] seconds to cut all your lights
off tell your wife to shut up lock up
and get downstairs in that little corner
room
all right you put your hand on her
shoulder firmly you don't hurt her but
you're not affectionate you place your
hand on her shoulder so she knows that
some pertinent [ __ ] information is on
the way you say honey we're the only
ones left
the other ones let look at me stop
crying
we're the only one we're the only ones
left with power and I need you to hold
it together cry it out now I want you to
cry every ounce of [ __ ] you have in you
out of you
in this corner miss house okay when you
come upstairs I want you to sit here and
act like we do not have power okay
so when the Sullivans come across the
[ __ ] street and see if we don't have
power
why did their [ __ ] faces Shh honey
forget about the cellphones they're not
going to make it you understand yeah I
don't want that to happen I don't want
that to happen to anybody but I don't
want to be the Sullivans you know what I
mean I want a shot just give me a
[ __ ] shot so I need I just need some
solar panels and a [ __ ] helicopter
and I will get the [ __ ] out of here
that's what you need you [ __ ] idiot
with your guns huh will you
Schwarzenegger how long's that going to
last
anyway so I'm thinking about it does
anybody is anybody live in the LA area
does anybody have solar panels anywhere
in the [ __ ] world can you recommend
are there two different kinds because I
actually looked up solar panels off the
grid and I came to this place a blue
Pacific solar it says off grid packages
then there's another one that just says
gets solar power Sun power off-grid
systems off-grid system backwoods solar
electric systems
yeah I can install that [ __ ] well we're
going to do is we're going to bring it
in and we'll just run it over the
outhouse
well what Cabana what's that a cigar um
sorry on a stupid [ __ ] load this week
umm yeah oh then there's one for
Australia I don't mind paying the grid
but I would like to have if the grid
fails to have the then off the grid
switch how about that can we just have
that those of you who've been on the
internet this week you know the
direction that I'm working in oh yes you
do the stop being modest you know the
direction I'm going in I'm talking about
solar [ __ ] roads has anybody seen
this this YouTube video it's [ __ ]
amazing if what they're saying is true
about these solar roads and I apologize
for the narrator I get what he's doing
he's trying to keep it interesting but
he kept it interesting too long and then
he brings it down to an interlude which
should have come a minute earlier and
then he goes back to screaming so it's a
little bit annoying but just try to
listen to the information and then try
not to get sucked into a George Bush
Obama debate because I don't know I
don't know if these things what the [ __ ]
do I know right but it's just they
basically saying if we replaced all our
roads with these solar [ __ ] things
that literally what makes it look like
Legoland and it's all lit up and there'd
be sensors to let you know what dere is
going around the corner and then it
would just light up in the turn a
there's a [ __ ] deer around the corner
you know enjoy your barley pancakes or
whatever right some [ __ ] full-on
hippy [ __ ] and that basically the amount
of energy that it would create would be
three times what this country even
needed which immediately we can just
leave the Middle East right we don't
have to be over there pissing them off
by getting in the middle of their
[ __ ] all right we don't have to deal
with oil
and oil money is what funds the
terrorists as far as my limited reading
goes right but the families over there
that [ __ ] hang on she's scratching I
just gave you a bet what's wrong
oh um anyways uh yeah like the [ __ ]
the the oil people over the people who
make all the money over there they've
been donate to mosques and then in the
mosque they [ __ ] you know kind of
[ __ ] a you know send it over to these
[ __ ] people over here that end up
coming back at us shooting [ __ ] at us as
far as you know well like I said I don't
know [ __ ] Cleo would you stop [ __ ]
you're gonna have to go to the other
room here come here buddy what's up
sweet huh we went on a nice hike today
didn't we huh this was good alright get
out of you so anyways yeah and then that
whole [ __ ] thing is just null and
void we have all this extra power works
you could create a bunch of jobs the
only thing I don't know is the way it
looks it doesn't seem like it's a smooth
ride it just seems like the whole time
you be going like over these [ __ ]
things I have no idea but just check it
out and I swear to God because this is
something that I don't know if it is if
it does work if it does [ __ ] work it
could benefit everybody conservatives
liberals independence everywhere who
wouldn't benefit from all of this energy
oh that's right the people in power how
could I forget that that's right how do
you think that they're going to derail
this if this actually becomes a movement
how will they somehow tie in terrorism
9/11 liberals [ __ ] right-wing
conservatives and just get this to pot
[ __ ] stirring so everybody's
screaming and yelling a little bit for
heaven Atlantic spective and the babies
will starve they're going to do all of
that [ __ ] the only way this thing gets
off the ground if it works if it works
is if people don't get sucked into those
arguments
and we all become one and we all pick up
a hatchet and we start marching towards
the bankers gated communities okay
because the asphalt streets will have to
run red with blue blood money before
something wonderful like this will ever
[ __ ] happen because you are [ __ ]
with a century and a half of cash flow
going to a small amount of people that's
what you're [ __ ] with and when you're
[ __ ] with something like that that
level of money basically the money that
gives the dollar power like the only
thing gives the US dollar powers that
oil barrels of oil are still measured in
US dollars other than that it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show so these guys are the
guys behind all of that
it's them in the [ __ ] bankers and
that's it all right the insurance
companies like the Ted Kennedy or that
[ __ ] family all right but [ __ ] it
Bobby and Jack all right actually the
banks are [ __ ] Joe Kennedy I feel
shut up at the Kennedy [ __ ] all right so
anyways that's my thing like this is a
great [ __ ] idea if it works if it
works it's a [ __ ] great idea even if
you just did a few roads if you just did
a few of them each state just it like
their main highway or whatever if you
just did that I can't imagine the amount
of money it would save and on the less
man it was in quite the possibilities of
it are incredible I don't know if it
works but it is [ __ ] incredible but
the sad thing is the fact that whenever
new stuff like this comes up it all just
turns into Obama Bush Republican
Democrat blah blah but everybody's just
yelling at each other and then it just
[ __ ] goes away and then everybody
turns on sports and that's what happens
so there you go
this is all off the grid Billy 15
minutes the crazy talk that makes sense
to me makes sense to me man [ __ ] you
know we get it going a bit forward so
[ __ ] liberal all them liberals out
there and Hollywood
right I gotta tell you I'm I'm not just
making fun of a stereotypical southern
guy all right because I haven't lived
out here in Hollywood these people are
out of their [ __ ] mind state they
have Fox News to the left they're out of
their [ __ ] minds there's such [ __ ]
hypocrites where it's just like you can
say the most I guess racist isn't the
word because you can make fun of white
people rich white people you can
basically you can be you can use the
exact [ __ ] thing that they don't like
seeing used on poor people against rich
people only [ __ ] love it you know you
can suggest that people from the South
are all [ __ ] their sisters and
they're slapping their knees and they're
doing the wave in the crowd all right
but if you suggest any homeless guy
needs to get off his [ __ ] ass stop
boozing and get a [ __ ] job then
you're the devil so I mean I don't know
does that make any sense well it
shouldn't isn't that why you listen to
this podcast you come
you
[Music]
even the
[Applause]
solar panels last week I talked about I
was thinking about maybe getting solar
panels off my house off my house on my
house and I don't know if I want to go
off the grid but whatever a city of
bacon in the Sun in this [ __ ] house I
might as well get something out of it
right all right so here we go hi bill
first off huge fan of your comedy
podcast thank you I saw you perform
Brian Regan well with Brian Regan cops
comedy while that was a bucket-list
night for me to be able to perform at
that guy show is absolutely hilarious
well thank you and thank you from Brian
Regan too anyway
regarding your question about solar
there is no solar power that it's
completely off the grid you use all the
energy that you can provide through
solar and the rest that can't be
provided by the Sun like at night or if
it gets shady on your roof the utility
provides this is called interconnection
you save a ton of money and you use
clean energy in the process I work for a
solar company I promise this isn't a
[ __ ] sales pitch and I manage the
construction timeline so I've learned a
lot about this stuff here's a link to my
company I work for we've installed a lot
in LA and in Boston as well - I think
we're in like 12 different states
anyways thanks you for the awesome
podcast and you know something about
this so it should this and every person
you talked to said something different I
watch people on YouTube make up a solar
thing what a solar thing put up their
solar panels broke down how they worked
and and how you could get off the grid
but it was really really really [ __ ]
involved this guys dig in a goddamn
trench I can't even what the [ __ ] is
going on but I'm just like I I don't
have a room for a trench I write my
little piece of property here so I don't
you know I got room for a hole does that
work I came in what he was doing they
dug this trench and he stuff like a
[ __ ] top in there I don't know what
that I can't even tell you what's going
on but I will definitely I'll definitely
look into it hopefully I'll have more
luck with you guys and the [ __ ] [ __ ]
who put the roof on this house
[ __ ] [ __ ] I told you what they
did like they put the roof on the house
and then like the drain pipes because
it's an old house old stupid design with
a drain off was it goes down into a pipe
that actually goes into like a I don't I
have like a my attic is actually
obviously seeing John Malkovich or being
Being John Malkovich remember they had
that floor we had to walk around bent
over like that's basically how much
space there is between the ceiling on my
top floor and then the roof I don't even
know what the purpose of it is all it is
is just just traps air that gets heated
up and causes my house to be hot but
anyways that's what it is so the drain
off of the water on the roof goes into a
pipe that goes in into the [ __ ]
crawlspace and then back out the front
of the house and down the side so you
take water from the roof you bring it
into the house it's inside a pipe but
nevertheless you're bringing into the
[ __ ] house and God forbid that pipe
bursts or you have some [ __ ] [ __ ]
who disconnects it when he's putting the
new roof on and forgets to hook it back
up and then tries to blame it on yet he
blamed it on oh you know the [ __ ] all
the bla bla bla and I'm just sitting
there going alright this is at least a
year in court you know what why don't
you just get the [ __ ] out of here I'll
just put in a goddamn claim you [ __ ]
that's what I did because I didn't want
to go to court
so anyways I'm hoping you you're better
than those guys
I mean how couldn't you be alright
here's my favorite one of this week
solar roadways debunked I got a note
from my guy here andrew says a ton of
people forwarded the same link as the
one in the email below I watched this so
you don't have to it's 30 minutes long
basically he [ __ ] about cost
maintenance in the efficient e
efficiency of the perks advertising
original video like heating repairing
the road yeah I actually watched the
first ten minutes of it I'll save my
opinion till I read this yo Billy the
sunburned kid I know you were pretty
pumped up about solar roses be honest so
was i but someone smarts at
down and crunch some numbers and brought
up points as why as to why solar roads
are economically intact technically not
feasible it's about 30 minutes long so
if you got some time to kill in any
Airport check it out well you know what
sir I watched the first 10 minutes of it
he didn't debunk them he just brought up
a bunch of questions he's just like a
road has to be durable and I would have
some questions about I mean they showed
a tractor run over the tiles but it was
a small tractor and they only did it
once
I would like to see how these you know
these things hold up when it's wet out
and you need water to run off and he
just brought up a bunch of [ __ ]
questions you know he didn't debunk them
he did basically basically what he did
it's like 50% what you have to do he
can't have somebody just come in on a
these are brand new roads can I make him
oh ok do you think they're good you
think they're gonna work ok I mean
obviously you can't do that
but it's 50% that which is smart you got
to ask the right questions and then the
other side is anytime you try to do
something new there's always people
saying it's not going to work you know
and this guy in his half hour I'm sure
he bring he brought up a number of
things that would be a problem it
doesn't mean they can't work ok so I
don't I wouldn't say they would debunked
I would just say somebody asked a bunch
of [ __ ] questions and rather than
just when what he does is he just throws
it out there it's like why don't you
contact the people at the solar Road who
trying to make the solar roads and
actually get some answers and get some
[ __ ] or maybe order some tiles and
try to do some experiments yourself
rather than wasting people's time with
the half hour of questions and
speculation that's basically what it was
so I wouldn't say that it was debunked
but you know you throw up three-pointers
for a half an hour some of them are
going to go in even if you suck so I'm
sure a couple of his concerns were true
but you know we look at electric cars
since way back in the day people who
show up they're [ __ ] up like people
actually question the power of electric
electricity it powers the entire [ __ ]
city can light up a whole [ __ ]
see and I get a Prius in my own mother
my own mother is going can it go up a
hill
no mom I just got to get out and start
walking it's great for my weight look at
that they saw their underpowered and
their this and then that first of all
the Prius is not an electric car it's
not even a [ __ ] 50 percent electric
car it's like an eight percent electric
car that's what it is from like zero
I've told you this guys four years from
zero to seven miles an hour that car
runs on electric power and then switches
over to gas for the rest of the time and
if you drive with a lead foot you're
going to get maybe twenty five miles a
gallon but if you listen do you listen
to the engine okay and you don't stop on
the gas and drive like a [ __ ] maniac
and slam on the brakes you can get you
know I don't I wouldn't say forty miles
a gallon yeah you can get like thirty
five but it's great perfect car if
you're living in the city I absolutely
love the [ __ ] thing so anyway so you
had that I bought that thing in October
of 2007 and now look at these these
Tesla cars I actually wrote in one of
those the end of last year before I
wrote in Casey's [ __ ] truck Jesus
Christ which probably gets two feet to
the gallon especially the way he was
driving it those Tesla cars are [ __ ]
amazing and you can drive from last
night check from San Diego all the way
up to Vancouver you know they have
recharge stations from San Diego all we
have to Vancouver and I think recently
someone just drove one across the
country so it's not like that guy in the
speculation video I got to look that one
up well you should look it up or
whatever but um I'm actually I'm leaning
towards that [ __ ] thing thing's
badass you walk up to when you turn it
on like the door handles are flush
against the car and you walk up and
things pop out I'm sure what it cars to
that I never seen
just called me
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday June the 6th 2009 and this is my
last couple of days here in New York
City I can't wait to get back to to Los
Angeles even though everybody [ __ ]
trashes that city I've never lived in a
city where so many people so openly just
[ __ ] trash it you know what I mean
it's weird hey what do you live
oh I lived in I live in uh st. Paul
Minnesota oh my god the place sucks
those people are so [ __ ] phony
yeah have another contrived snowball
fight you know I don't know whatever
people always I don't want people go to
[ __ ] LA is they they go down to
[ __ ] right on the Sunset Strip and
then they [ __ ] talk about how
Hollywood and phony it is really when
you go to Georgia do you go to Atlanta
or do you go to like [ __ ] Macon
Georgia renomii I can't believe how many
you I can't believe how many rednecks
there were there well you [ __ ] went
to ground zero of it yet dumb [ __ ] um
I'm grumpy this week I'm grumpy this
week cuz I don't want to [ __ ] be here
anymore I just realized that I don't
wanna be here anymore which is great
because this is my last day of shooting
I am having a great time when I am on
the set but when I am off the set and
I'm trying to figure out what the [ __ ] I
do in a city that I already lived in for
12 [ __ ] years you know what am I
going to get another slice am I going to
go to Central Park for the ninetieth
million [ __ ] time ninety million
[ __ ] time is what I'm trying to say
there I was drinking yesterday and like
the afternoon you know went in to watch
the Red Sox play the Mariners at some
bar and my buddy he came in for the
first three innings and then he left and
I was like you know what I'm going to
hang out and I just sort of just stayed
there and I had like five Heinekens in
the middle of the day now I know how you
youngsters out there like five Heinekens
in the middle of the day will you a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what I said it's all you got I don't
know what the ages but there becomes an
age
Jesus Christ something I got like a
[ __ ] double chin look at myself in
the mirror that's when you know you've
been boozing if you get a like a [ __ ]
two days scruff and all of a sudden you
got like that Pelican chin ah [ __ ]
mess like you know I don't know I got to
get out of here that's the [ __ ] point
so anyway so I have like five beers and
who's that perf you know five beers is
like what that that point where you
don't think you're drunk so you continue
talking to people and I don't know it
just sucks
drinking the middle day sucks because
you go through the whole [ __ ]
hangover you know usually when you just
pass out at the end of the night I mean
you sleep through most of your [ __ ]
hangover as opposed to this one where I
came off and I just sort of gradually
came down and I would nod off like a
[ __ ] old man and then wake up back
again and just wake up back again
doesn't make any sense I'd wake up again
I don't know I'm all over the [ __ ]
place I want to get out of here
I've had it [ __ ] had it I've had it
so anyways I went up to see some family
over the fourth of July to celebrate the
birthday of this country and as I'm
driving up I'm listening on the radio
and evidently I looked up the song on on
the internet it's a Carrie Underwood
song who I don't I don't know what she
is I'm guessing she's white because it
sounded country and she had a little
twang in her voice but I don't want to
piss off any Koreans out there she might
have been Korean um is a song called
before he cheats so I'm driving along
and you know I'm driving my buddy's car
this is how I'm going to [ __ ] defend
myself that I was on a radio station I
was actually playing this and I was just
sort of clicking the the pre-program
radios [ __ ] whatever you know what
I'm saying I'm feel like [ __ ] cut me
some slack this week so anyways this
song comes on
on and this this Carrie Underwood chick
is sitting there singing this song going
right now he's probably slow dancing bad
with the frat now and she's singing
about her boyfriend I got the lyrics
right here right now he's probably
buying her some fruity little drink
because she can't shoot whiskey right
now he's probably up behind her with the
pool stick showing her how to shoot a
combo and then they go into the the
chorus and she goes and he don't know
that I dug my T's and to the side of his
pretty little souped up four-wheel drive
carved my name into his leather seats I
took a Louisville Slugger to both
headlights slashed a hole in all four
tires and all I could think was why
don't you just break up with them you
dumb [ __ ] you know what I mean what are
you going to do you're going to do all
this [ __ ] then he's going to get mad and
then what you're going to make up after
five days and then you're going to blow
them again I hate this [ __ ] song and
I'm going to tell you why because it's
I'm pretty sure it's a hit it's on the
radio right I don't know and you know I
love about this is people will listen to
this song and they won't even question
the rationale of what the [ __ ] someone's
doing in there because so many people in
life myself included you play it you
like powerless in life you just play the
powerless card you know just get out of
the [ __ ] relationship I [ __ ] hate
this song
and this is one of these songs too we're
[ __ ] women all get together they
start seeing a cat Mikey there's a car
you're all a bunch of dumb [ __ ] okay
you're [ __ ] stupid
just break up with the guy just break up
with them not even to mention the fact
that now you're going out there and
you're doing damage you I don't know is
that a fella that's not a felony I don't
know what it is but it's just a classic
thing where a woman would listen to that
song and at no point would she ever
think maybe I could get arrested
for this I am damaging somebody's
property no you got a [ __ ] vagina you
can just go out in broad daylight
you don't have to wear a [ __ ] mask do
you know what I would have to do if I
wanted to go out and go [ __ ] up
somebody's car I would have to wait but
first of all I have to make sure I had
an alibi it'd be like I was killing
somebody I had to make sure somebody
could cover for me and say that I was
[ __ ] somewhere right I had to put on
some goddamn cat suit and a [ __ ] mask
right like I'm in that dead presidents
movie and all I would able to get I'd be
able to get off one quick hit right one
quick hit less I want to start carving
it up like a [ __ ] right but if I really
was going to go out there and smash
somebody's headlights I could hit one
and the second the car alarm goes off I
have to [ __ ] take off and then run
home get out of my little [ __ ]
[ __ ] cat suit and then try to put on
my pajamas
so when the cops show up because you
know they're going to find some sort of
[ __ ] fingerprint I got to act like
I'm not out of breath like I actually
have been sitting there for [ __ ]
eight hours watching TV I know I just I
can't stand you know it just reminds me
of when that movie
fatal attraction came out right and the
amount of women who is just sit there
and you see that movie huh yeah that's
what you get that's what you get you
know there's no thought of like this
[ __ ] put a rabbit in in boiling water
there's none of that women I did there
how did they have [ __ ] minds but
that's not even the point of this my
point of the Carrie Underwood song it
actually made me feel like a loser
because the amount of [ __ ] times I
mean I'm going on [ __ ] up somebody's
car but the amount of times you know
what is that song is that song it's a
powerless song that's what the [ __ ] it
is and I went through the whole lyrics
to see if she breaks up with them in the
end and there's sort of an ambiguous
line in the end where she goes uh
because the next time he cheats oh you
know it won't be on me so that's sort of
ambiguous because it could mean because
I broke up with them or it could be
because he doesn't want to get his truck
[ __ ] up
so I don't know you know I just I just
[ __ ] annoys me that song just annoyed
the [ __ ] out of me on both levels well
you got somebody it's like just break up
with the guy and your solution is you
know something if a girl ever [ __ ]
cheated on me that that's I would break
up with them I'm not saying I wouldn't
flip out and give him a good [ __ ]
thrashing verbally but I would never go
in like what you know throw all their
clothes out in the front lawn and burn
him you know why wouldn't I do that I
don't know why I think a lot of it has
to do because I'd be [ __ ] word I get
arrested for damaging property why do
women have an exemption from damaging
property I don't understand it of a
woman sat there smashing up somebody's
car in broad daylight because the guy
cheated on him people would be laughing
I would be laughing everyone would get
it's a comedy it's just hilarious but at
the exact same scenario was going down
and a guy did it he could be the classic
you know the cops come and they put you
in that little you get tasered and they
mush your face into the [ __ ] pavement
I don't know I get it women have to
carry a kid around in their goddamn
stomach for nine months but I don't
think that gives you the right to go out
and attack somebody's Fiero I really
don't you know so why don't you guys
just [ __ ] relax all right
you a bunch of goddamned psychos you
know with your I'm on my period excuse
of three weeks a month you're out of
your [ __ ] mind I think in what girl
goes even if you were cheating on a girl
or on a woman right and she [ __ ] up
your car I really think you ought to be
able to go up to her and give her a nice
[ __ ] two-piece combination to the
goddamn [ __ ] cabbage what do you
think about that right just [ __ ] just
hook off on that [ __ ] hair teased
head of lettuce on the top of her
[ __ ] shoulders right
what would you go with I'm really going
to alienate
a lot of my cents on this cookin and I
want you to know that most of this is
not me advocating punching a woman in
the face most of this is I can't [ __ ]
sit in this stupid hotel room anymore I
can't [ __ ] do it I've had the goddamn
Do Not Disturb light on for like four
days they probably think I overdosed in
here
I'm really big on that don't clean up
the room beat it you know he had it
coming in every three days and change
the sheets like I'm royalty I change the
sheets like [ __ ] once every three
weeks maybe that's only if that's only
if they're white and I can tell how
filthy they are
that's right wrinkle your nose up you
[ __ ] pompous broads that's how I love
my life
Jesus why am i attacking women I don't
know what was I talking about oh yeah if
you could punch a woman in the face you
a lot of two punches what would you go
with okay would you go classic would you
set up the overhand right with the jab
would you actually waste the jet you
know waste a jab would you go this is
just evil all right I gotta get off this
[ __ ] subject I know that song just
annoyed me
I hate those [ __ ] songs when women
just just openly talk about how they're
going to go out and destroy a guy's
[ __ ] property rather than break up
with them you know and it's considered
some sort of justification you know
rather than looking inward going you
know maybe I'm a bad judge of character
what sort of qualities of am I looking
for in somebody and I'll date that I
mean didn't the fact that the guy had a
souped-up four-wheel-drive truck didn't
that give it or didn't that give it away
on any [ __ ] level huh and it's let me
a souped-up four-wheel-drive truck
Carrie Underwood you dumb [ __ ] and what
else did he have huh a [ __ ] earring
hanging down with a lightning bolt on
the side of it have this [ __ ] song
stinks this is one of the you know why I
hate this on this is and I'm going to do
my whole podcast on this [ __ ] song
this is going to be one of those [ __ ]
songs when I'm the on the road and I'm
hating my life you know and I just don't
want to go back to the hotel room and be
lonely and I'm going to go out to a
are and that song is going to come on
and [ __ ] for [ __ ] [ __ ] with their
ear piercing I'm singing and I'm drunk
high-pitched voices are going to start
singing every [ __ ] word of that song
like that they're like these [ __ ]
[ __ ] badasses okay and I'm done alright
I'm done with that I'm done with this
[ __ ] hot Jesus Christ that [ __ ]
song annoyed me what a [ __ ] loser
that Carrie Underwood is huh is that an
anthem for all you broads out there you
know I love about this is I'm really
like I'm really taking the literally the
dumbest demographic of women and I'm
just [ __ ] superimposing it over all
women and I'm doing it on purpose
because this because I'm childish this
week I'm [ __ ] in a bad mood and you
know rather than doing some yoga and
going out and getting a veggie omelet or
whatever dumb [ __ ] you're supposed to do
would you look at my [ __ ] face this
bloated booze face Jesus Christ what
happened I wasn't you know my life was
great I came to New York goin okay this
is awesome you know living a dream here
and I'm gonna I'm gonna eat right I'm
not going to drink I'm gonna work out
everyday and you know I don't know what
happened well I know what happened was
this the second day I got here was my
birthday so you got a drink on your
birthday and then I just got the booze
coursing through my veins and then it's
just it's just been it's just been I
came to a drunken debauchery it's just
been sort of sad old man I've kind of
been sitting there like norm in Cheers
if he didn't know anybody you know cliff
Clavin didn't come in and butcher his
name with his bad Boston accent Haven
mami nom it's norm just take the r up if
you want to do a Boston accent that's
what you do you just take the r out
everything doesn't become an a I know
I've mentioned that before but you know
the deal is people in North Dakota I
went there
Fargo and I brought up that movie and
they would just like dude we don't
[ __ ] talk like that that movie was
annoying but everyone else thought it
was hilarious
because how many of us have ever been to
Fargo North Dakota and the same thing
with cheers you know everybody thinks
now that that's how they say norm
they say nah me now they don't they say
norm alright does this make any [ __ ]
sense this is just like I am like I'm
just come to the week right now what
else did I want to talk about that I do
anything this week I don't think I did
anything I started to read a book
reading a book on the mob why don't I
just start reading some [ __ ] because I'm
actually this is my last day of shooting
and I'm excited I'm really excited about
this scene because I have the most lines
of any scene you know and any scene that
I that I Bennett which means I have 1.5
now kidding I actually got like two or
three lines which is going to be cool
and I'm really excited to do this [ __ ]
but I gotta get this [ __ ] podcast out
of the way can you tell I'm scrolling
down alright here's why I got this is
dude in England who always [ __ ]
emails me and I guess he was sick of me
not reading his questions or whatever so
in the title whatever he called the
subject line he said read this you
[ __ ] [ __ ] so of course I have to open
it and he said sorry you're not a [ __ ] I
just need to get your attention alright
hey Bill
dynamite podcast this week or should I
say last week well because it's
Wednesday and oh look no Monday morning
podcasts because I was really looking
forward to hearing you talk about your
dog for 40 minutes again dude we get it
you have a dog no one cares be funnier
haha
that's my main point also rename the
podcast bill burr speaks for 40 minutes
because for a start it's hardly ever out
on a Monday and also you do ramble
aimlessly it's called a podcast you
[ __ ] [ __ ] what do you think a
podcast is are there a bunch of podcast
out there where people aren't babbling
aim lessly podcasts are basically
[ __ ] radio shows for people who
weren't good enough to be on the [ __ ]
radio so I don't know what's what level
of quality you're looking for here but
you really need to lower your standards
all right and who the [ __ ] says dynamite
are they still saying that over there
did you guys just get good times all
right here we go let's continue here um
anyways I'm not trying to trash you
because sometimes it's great oh that's
cool I'm glad sometimes it's great
I just think bill burr speaks for 40
minutes is a better title take a lead my
advice but my main point stop talking
about the dog it kills me I fast forward
when when when you do nobody cares about
your [ __ ] dog but apart from that the
show is great and I love your work one
quick question I can see I would be
annoying if I was talking to my dog I
know there's a bunch of animal lovers
right now listen is going no I really
enjoy it [ __ ] you dude I love my dog all
right why don't you go get some fish and
chips and not brush your teeth or
whatever other hacky [ __ ] thing you
guys do over there huh deed a pork chop
for breakfast yeah man I'm trying to
think the last good-looking person that
came from England Pete Townsend with
that warped nose was there anybody
good-looking even what's-his-face Roger
Daltrey who was in shape but his face is
just beat just beat down man you just
weathered weathered [ __ ] people over
there I can't I don't think I've ever
remembered that anybody ever saying they
met some hot chick in England I've heard
it you know you go to France you go to
Sweden you know you go to Spain right
you go to Puerto Rico there's all kinds
of [ __ ] hot women you go to England
dude look at the royal family actually
Princess Diana was kind of hot but she
had weird [ __ ] hands and feet she
looked like she was part lizard she was
you look like a beautiful lizard that's
what she that's what she looked like and
Prince Charles looks like
uh you know what I don't have the
[ __ ] medical background to talk about
how inbred that guy is you know what I
mean but he just basically I don't know
I don't know what he has he has one of
whatever the [ __ ] he has and it's all
the same coursing through his [ __ ]
body whatever if a regular mutt human
being has just shut up you're too
[ __ ] stupid to go through with this
alright one quick question bill how long
did it take to crack the stand-up scene
I mean when you started getting decent
money and radio spots let's see well it
took me three and a half years before I
quit my day job but I was living at home
and I saved every dime that I made from
work that I could and I also saved every
dime that I was making from stand-up and
I basically saved up ten grand which
believe it or not you can do if you
don't run out and buy every new [ __ ]
iPhone iPod and all the laptops and all
that [ __ ] I didn't do any of that I just
dressed like Malcolm young and ac/dc
jeans and t-shirt I had a [ __ ] I had
this old pickup truck that I used to
drive two-wheel drive one of the little
ones and I drove that until it [ __ ]
died and I was at this critical point
where I was only a year into my stand-up
career and I needed a reliable car but I
also didn't want to be chained in my job
by buying a new car which is the dumbest
[ __ ] thing you can do if you're in
your 20s and you got some job and it's
not your business it's not your own
business and you know you want to leave
it at some point the dumbest [ __ ]
thing you can do is go out buy a brand
new car you just change yourself to your
desk I know I've said this before but
it's like that you know I remember in a
Bronx Tale when those bikers are acting
like [ __ ] and they ask him to leave
and they don't leave and then they
[ __ ] you know put the thing on the
door and then Chaz parlamentary goes now
you can't leave you're doing the
financial equivalent of that
when you go out and buy a brand-new
[ __ ] car okay first of all you can't
afford a good car you're just going to
get some generic [ __ ] 20,000 $25,000
stupid ass [ __ ] car and it's it's
gonna it's going to chain you to death
so long story short what I did was
instead of buying a new car was I just I
had a new engine put in like put in my
truck and everybody all the [ __ ]
people at work told me that's a dumbest
thing do what do you want in you would
do for will you [ __ ] really cost me
50 at the time because cost about
fifteen hundred bucks to get the whole
thing done right as opposed to having a
fifteen thousand dollar car loan I had
the [ __ ] engine paid off you know in
about four or five months then I had no
car payment again and I could use that
to put towards my nest egg and my idea
when I went down in New York was I was
going to get a day job but uh you know
well you know I waited a couple weeks
before I started looking and I started
doing stand-up and then I got a couple
of gigs and they were on the road so I
couldn't get a day job and believe me my
ten grand was [ __ ] going down down
down down down but it bought me enough
[ __ ] time where I could I could get
in with the clubs start getting gigs and
what ended up happening I think I went
all the way down to like [ __ ] 2500
bucks and I think that's when I started
booking [ __ ] that's what happened and I
started booking [ __ ] and I was able to
sustain it didn't get below 2500 but it
didn't really get above three grand
either I got to that point where I could
I could basically pay my bills and
that's all so back when somebody told me
about you know paying off your [ __ ]
credit cards every month so you don't
get [ __ ] with the on the interest I
started doing that and I basically I ate
spaghetti like every [ __ ] night pasta
is a really cheap meal it fills you up I
told you about this [ __ ] before and when
I went on the road I would go to Denny's
or the International
so pancakes and I get the large stack of
pancakes in the morning I get the five
stack and they would sit in my stomach
like [ __ ] cement and I could
literally go from like 8:00 in the
morning to 8:00 at night without eating
and you know I Drive my little rented
[ __ ] Dodge Neon to some college gig
there you go when you get a college gig
that's a big thing so about three and a
half years all right I'm sorry dude was
that [ __ ] boring I know I didn't talk
about my dog and dude I am just breaking
your balls sometimes like people give me
[ __ ] and I get my [ __ ] back and people
think I'm serious
I really don't give a [ __ ] alright now
here's his overrated underrated list
overrated bilborough's dog
no one cares bruce springsteen bloated
overrated stadium rocker barack obama he
can't Bahat he can't hide behind the
black forever
the economy is still [ __ ] Jesus Christ
dude did you even proofread this he
can't hide behind the black forever the
economy is still [ __ ] dude I don't
know if you [ __ ] notice but we had a
we've had a war for a good [ __ ] seven
years to the tune of a billion dollars a
month and bankers loaned out money to
homeless people and we had to bail them
out so I think I don't give a [ __ ] who
the [ __ ] you are Republican Democrat
liberal conservative [ __ ] independent
you're not getting us out of this which
is why I am going to Sweden I have a gig
coming up in Sweden in the end of August
I'm going to start doing Australia once
a year this talks about me going to
Dublin these [ __ ] overseas gigs are
very hard to get you know [ __ ] usually
ends up falling out but that's my thing
alright if these corporations are going
global I'm going global too I don't give
a [ __ ] I'll be the goddamn James Bond a
comedy James Bond
I don't know international man of jokes
underrated Arctic Monkeys
it's a great British band from Sheffield
England cocaine brilliant song by Eric
Clapton dude you must be young okay
that song is great the first 40,000
times you hear it burn it
underrated football / soccer
easily the best sport ever hands down
you know what I wouldn't argue that I
wouldn't argue that because if you
actually if you watch American soccer it
sucks like an American teen version
American team but if you watch that
overseas [ __ ] you know where people
[ __ ] die and people get trampled and
crushed to death and then they go on
YouTube and talk about how dumb
Americans are you know you think what
those awful English teeth you could eat
your way through the fence when you're
getting crushed up against the people in
England even have bad teeth there's my
entire [ __ ] understanding of England
basically 3 Austin power movies all
right probably is all right let's talk
about grenades again this week I asked
somebody when you throw a grenade how
long do you have before the [ __ ]
thing goes up and it said bill three to
four seconds sounds about right
I'm still amazed at that crazy son of a
[ __ ] who was filming didn't use a
tripod or some [ __ ] oh yeah if you guys
want to see what a [ __ ] grenade does
go on YouTube look up grenade in washing
machine I believe that's what you search
some army guy because I asked last week
you know whenever you see those army
movies somebody dives on a [ __ ]
grenade and you know saves the life of
his comrades I don't know it's
conflicting advice that I got on this
[ __ ] you know dude I'm [ __ ] losing it
right now this podcast is quickly
spinning out of control because I
haven't eaten yet and I have an early
pickup today and if I don't do it now
it's not going to be coming out on
Monday so I don't know I'm just start
reading [ __ ] here all right if you want
to talk about weaponry what about so
what is a question I asked last week oh
I asked I asked if there's any people in
the military if they had any combat
stories because I was talking about you
know whenever you fantasize about going
to war you always picture yourself doing
some Rambo [ __ ] but in the back II ahead
you know that there's a strong
possibility that you might be that
[ __ ] dude who when the [ __ ] goes down
you can't move you
freeze or you [ __ ] balled up in the
fetal position crying you know I heard a
story one time is sometimes in battle
people just stand up they can't deal
with it anymore and they just killed
themselves granted I heard that from my
high school teacher who's teaching the
English and he had never been to war you
know so that's probably [ __ ] anyway
so here's a guy actually went to come
babysit Bill you asking your podcasts
about the first time you're outside the
wire which is military jargon for
leaving protected base in Iraq or
Afghanistan and this dude said I was
absolutely terrified for the first
couple of weeks but the trick is that
you can't let anybody around you know
that you're scared because you don't
want you don't want to look like a [ __ ]
the rules of engagement are strict we
were ordered to not shoot back unless we
could we could see who was shooting at
us is that true
you couldn't shoot back unless you saw
who was shooting back at you dude I
would break that rule if I wasn't on the
ground crying in the fetal position god
oh my god shoot mattis I don't want to
do this if I could actually get past
that I would be definitely shooting in
the general [ __ ] direction of
whatever was do [ __ ] that [ __ ] that this
war is different from other wars insofar
as we are fighting right in the middle
of where normal people lived and we
tried hard not to kill any of them you
know what I'm not a student of military
history but I think most wars are kind
of where people are at I think back in
the Revolutionary days that you would go
out and stand in the line out in the
field or even in the Civil War but I
know they had the front in World War one
but at some point when you're kicking
the other teams ass you end up in their
back yard because a lot of them don't
just give up like well you you beat us
on our field we wouldn't want to go into
this town and hide amongst the civilians
you know am i wrong there I don't know
if I'm wrong I know how to
just didn't happen if you know I don't
know well I don't [ __ ] know dude I'm
out of it let's just get to the [ __ ]
questions for the week and I can I can
gradually [ __ ] bail out of this thing
okay over eight an underrated bill
people [ __ ] about the gas prices are I
guess overrated bill people [ __ ] about
the greedy oil companies whenever there
are high gas prices and also about how
there are no alternative energy options
for transportation what they don't seem
to understand is that no sane entre
entrepreneur is going to invest a dime
in developing alternative energy until
gas gets to ten dollars a gallon and
people are converting their vacuum
cleaners into segways to get to work we
can either have one or the other
dude it's not quite as simplistic as
that yeah that definitely has to be some
sort of outrage from the people but you
know what
rather than get into [ __ ] details
look up a guy Stan Maher any ye er this
guy actually came up with a car that ran
on water rain water freshwater saltwater
it did make a [ __ ] difference
and he basically figured out a way where
you could get across the country 14 and
a half gallons and the dumb [ __ ] told
people about it went to the news they
announced and on we played it on the
Opie and Anthony show they talked about
it on the news and then they said that
there was somebody from the Pentagon who
was so excited they sent a
lieutenant-colonel out there to check
out his device basically what happens is
when you come up with some [ __ ] like
that is they go out there and they they
sort of tell you that it's very wise for
you to buy to sell them the patent of it
you know and then if you don't play ball
you mysteriously died four or five years
later and your invention disappears
Stan Maher look it up that's what the
[ __ ] happens all right dude I've always
used the iPod a to do a bit about this
[ __ ] you're telling me basically that I
can have my entire [ __ ] record
collection you know eight thousand
[ __ ] songs in my pocket
but they can't come up with a car that
can't do better with the gas mileage
dude it's all [ __ ] would you
basically have at the top is you have
robbed the robber baron blue blood blood
families and some of the underworld guys
who went legitimate and the government
is middle management for these
[ __ ] and the guys at the top
they run everything banks are at the top
and then the blue blood guys I think the
corporations are the next level and then
it's the politicians okay this is coming
from a completely uninformed jackass
[ __ ] that I've read a couple of books
but I think that that's what's going on
that's what's going on and you know I
don't know how you can invent [ __ ]
nowadays and actually get it out to the
public you have to basically be working
for a corporation that has the money to
put it out there so then basically they
own it you know what I mean I guess you
could kind of try and be the Tyler Perry
of [ __ ] inventing [ __ ] you know what
can I just tap out of this [ __ ]
podcast I don't know what the hell I'm
talking about I'm [ __ ] on the road
I'm lonely I want to see my [ __ ] dog
I want to get back to my girl I'm gonna
get back to my [ __ ] life and I want
to do a good job today on set so I don't
[ __ ] this thing up because I've had a
great goddamn time and I fly back in a
couple of days in a couple of [ __ ]
days and I'm really looking forward to
it oh did I tell you guys I bought the
hangover when I was drunk in the bar
I bought the hangover off some [ __ ] I
don't know 50-year old Asian woman came
walking in you know it was great
it's like [ __ ] portable uh
Blockbuster Video and I bought the
hangover for five bucks
great bootleg copy only a couple times
did somebody stand up and walk by do you
got you know that's the great thing
about living in New York is all the
bootleg movies that you can [ __ ] buy
and basically someone just goes into the
movie theater with a video camera and
they just film the screen and it's great
because you can hear other people
laughing it's kind of like Mystery
Science Theater then somebody kind of
just there their seat in front and all
of a sudden you see somebody's head and
you're trying to look around it
you know but somebody just gets up in
the middle and starts walking down the
road and it's it's funny to me but
actually I saw it man I was alright it
was it was [ __ ] all right I guess
five bucks can you compliant can you
complain I wish I met this lady at the
beginning of my [ __ ] trip out here I
would have had out what about like fifty
eight of them yeah so next time you're
in New York all right and that cute
little asian lady comes walking in good
am I really doing this am i advocating
the stealing of [ __ ] I think it's over
anyways people send me emails a I listen
to all your uninformed uh I downloaded
them for free sorry
they always got to tell you that they
got your [ __ ] for free and then they say
sorry you don't I mean I pay for my
musics you [ __ ] [ __ ] pay for my
comedy all right whatever that's the end
of this podcast um I'm literally dizzy
right now the [ __ ] of my typing all
right next week I go back to my life as
a stand-up comedian I'm going to be at
the punchline in San Francisco on Monday
July the 13th and I'm doing two shows
and it's going to be just like the last
time where I'm going to try to do as
little material from my act as humanly
possible and I'm just going to tell you
some fucked-up stories from my childhood
from my dating life to to whatever you
know and then the following week I'm
going to be at the Comedy Works in
Denver Colorado
that's the 23rd 24th and 25th and then I
believe I'm gearing up to do another
special so I'm going to be on the road
pretty much right through August
September October November and December
I am pretty much going to be doing three
out of four weeks on the road and I'm
going to be getting this [ __ ] special
together and hopefully I will be
shooting it in San Francisco that is
that is the goal to shoot it in San
Francisco and to have a very funny
memorable special that's what the [ __ ] I
want to do and the stress of it is
already starting to hit me because
I don't know you know you don't want it
to suck you don't want it to suck the
reality is is I wish I had another
[ __ ] six months just because I'm lazy
but I know if it is [ __ ] all right
I'm just I'm just really I'm babbling
I need nourishment I need to stop
drinking and I need to go downstairs
under the treadmill and somehow get some
of this [ __ ] booze weight out of my
goddamn chin all right that's it that's
the Monday morning podcast if I had to
critique this podcast I would say would
it was like when Evel Knievel tried to
jump the Snake River in that rocket you
know where it started off fast and you
thought I was going to [ __ ] him that's
what the I did you don't happen to this
podcast the [ __ ] parachute came out
halfway through it and then I just
slowly went down towards the Snake River
and actually have a bloody nose right
now just like Evel Knievel all right I'm
gonna go get some eggs god bless you
hope to see you in if you live anywhere
near San Francisco hope to see you out
at my gig and please keep the questions
coming next week I'm going to give you a
great podcast because I'll be back in my
home life and I'll be eating right and I
won't be drinking and brace yourself
douche bag from England I'm probably
gonna be talking about how excited I am
to see my [ __ ] dog all right that's
it everybody have a good team
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
you